it was emotional it's really sad and
goodbyes cuz we're splitting up we're
really sorry that you're so sad but I
got regular I'm happy that you're saying
yeah yeah we then we did a good job
actually
when you read the script before the
season 3 finale what was your initial
reaction when I watched it it thank you
watching have you seen it did you stop
it you saw the last steps no I have a
video on my phone I'm going to post of
me sobbing I yeah I was pretty
mind-blowing even shooting it was just
like so really sad
yeah but it was pretty incredible I
forget completely what my reaction was I
think it was just such a blur at the
time is because like they usually fit
right in the show Wow the season 3
finale scare scripts mid filming like so
will be in the middle of working yeah
and they'll finish it and send it and
like I said it I'll figure it out ok
it's also it's also cool over reading
your own stuff because then when you
watch everybody else's stuff it's like
it's comma shot yeah because really need
to know your own stuff I was super
pumped I think I just read my stuff
usually I mean I feel like everyone's
kind of guilty of just like at first
skipping to their stuff and then going
back and reading all as your character
you don't really know everybody else's
situations right so it makes sense not
to know what's good but yeah when I read
the full thing but we saw all of it so
I'm like really pumped about it
[Music]
it's been an honor official to play the
role I think that's all I have to say
it's just that spending hugely
creatively fulfilling and I was really
happy with my story on this season
perfect so I guess the final scene as
some would call it like the climax
there's a really nice tail end where you
just coast into wrapping up all these
storylines you have to read a couple
times to really get the gist of what's
going on especially the more
action-filled it gets you know it's a
lot of descriptions and it's sometimes
it's quite hard to visualize until
you're there and set you're like oh
that's what's going on it's always an
exciting thing because that's for us
that's like us watching it for the
audience you know it's our first time
introduced the materials are first like
whoa moments and it's always written so
well it's like a book but you know the
the endings are always ups and downs
right there was a bit of a roller
coaster there you do yeah at the end it
was really sad to film I mean
potentially the last time we're gonna be
at the buyers house you know for me that
was the first time I the first shot I
ever had was inside the buyers house so
to kind of see it and pack it up and be
over in that location it's really sad
and and goodbyes because we're splitting
up so I have no I really don't have any
idea you know where we'll be next year
heart to heart what is that I thought it
was stunning I mean I don't know how
these guys can outdo themselves because
I remember thinking season 1 was so
extraordinary to do is Oaks turn heir
and then I was like you'll never be able
to have the payoffs that you had
especially the season 1 payoff but then
even that season 2 payoff for closing
the gate you'll never be able to do it
and they did it like tenfold I mean I've
never been so impressed with a script
there's not a lagging moment it is such
an honor to work on this show really for
the fans who have just finished binging
it what message do you want to give to
them they're reaching for oh my gosh
sorry you're so sad I really hope you
liked we're really sorry that you're so
sad but I've got regular I'm happy that
you're saying yeah yeah we then we did a
good
exactly okay ready for season 4 because
please is this gonna come out off to the
show after please keep the door Oh open
security it changes keep the door open 3
inches
oh I think I'm at the curiosity I am The
Cure 2 doors and you enjoy the show
thank you so much see you in season 4 or
if we have
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]